You know,
I think the funny thing is at one point
in time I would have really sought and
definition,
I wouldn't have really sought to say
that I identify with these set of people
more that identity and what has always
happened when I've tried to do that has
been,
you know,
being essentially slapped in the face
and look,
it's not that simple and it shouldn't
be,
that's important.
If you do try to simplify it,
you're doing great harm to yourself and
your understanding of the world.
So,
you know,
at this point in time I sort of put that
to the side and said,
you know what,
the characterizations,
the definitions are going to come and
whoever it is that's going to,
to,
to want you to fall into particular
line,
whether it for whatever purpose is going
to,
they're going to do that regardless of
what you say.
So for you,
you have to create that open space for
yourself.
And that space is not one or the other.
It will never be one or the other.
It's,
um,
it's,
it's a space that's,
that's infused with so many things.
But I think what's great about that as
well is that,
you know,
being,
being Nigerian and being American rate,
you understand,
I don't think you begin to understand
that,
that it,
it,
it gets really,
really absurd because of being American,
right?
Is being influenced by so many different
cultures.
So many different traditions that have
come into this country from,
you know,
whether they were here to start with or
whether they have come in through
immigrants,
right.
Uh,
being Nigerian is very much the same
because the idea of being Nigerian is
influenced by all the different groups
and cultures and subcultures that go on.
And then you add to the fact that
there's a whole relation between Nigeria
and for example,
the UK,
which colonized in Nigeria and then now
growing connections between Nigeria and
the United States,
right?
And American culture through,
whether it's through hip hop music or
movies,
films,
whatever,
have come in and are now starting to
influence the way that people think.
So the idea of what it means to be
Nigerian is actually,
it's a very,
it's a very fractured thing.
It's a,
it's a Malandra things.
And it just,
it seems different.
Okay.
Because everybody in Nigeria tends to
have brown skin,
right?
That doesn't necessarily mean everyone's
the same.
Here you see the differences more,
right?
But at the same time,
people like to,
to,
to sort of smooth over that with,
oh,
we're American.
But you know,
American again is so many different
things.
And you know,
in the end,
if I say I'm American,
what does that mean that I am,
that means I've taken bits and pieces
from this.
I've taken bits and pieces from that and
put it into this identity.
So I just,
you know,
I'd say like for purposes of,
of travel and characterization,
right?
If I have to show a passport,
I'll show which passport is most
necessary,
but when it comes down to what I think I
am and how I perceive myself,
I think,
you know,
acknowledging that it's,
it's a whole,
like a multiplicity of things allows me
to better relate to myself and to other
people and to,
to better deal with the world as a
whole.
I think.